for the mariners they will counter with
they will start with you say kikuchi who
had his last start skipped of course
because of the neck issue mookie bat
steps in they'll leap things off for the
dodgers wookie won for three last night
and line drive snared by no live one
down
for clayton kershaw making his fourth
start of the campaign a record of two
wins and one loss came off a very good
start last friday night here is
shortstop dylan moore jp crawford with
the night off
the curve lands at the knees back to
back kays on that curve ball two out
matt baby stepping in
the dodgers this year 294 with runners
in scoring position they've got a threat
here in the third inning
now the 2-2
and there's a fly ball to right
well hit and it's a fair ball and it
bounces over the wall for a ground rule
double hernandez will score barnes will
go to third baby the rbi and the dodgers
take a one to nothing lead and he was on
his left knee and that pitch was in the
low 90s so runners at second and third
base
for mookie betts
off the glove of odom here comes barnes
from third and the dodgers lead to
nothing
the pitch
caught on and missed that was on the
fringe
now pollock coming up pollock flied to
right his first time here with a man at
third and one gone and an 0-1
hits it on the ground through a drawn in
infield for a base hit to left and then
comes matt baby to make it three nothing
pollux at second base there's two out
and bellinger coming up
corbin in a fastball last night he pulls
a fast ball into right center field here
pollock will come in to score the
dodgers lead four nothing on a two out
single from cody bellinger and he was
very aggressive and they did give him a
first pitch fastball for some reason
here's joseph odom odom batting ninth
mariner's trailing
the pitch
a curve drops in for strike three and
clayton kershaw is tied with don
drysdale
for the second most strikeouts in
franchise history here's dylan moore
32 year old clayton kershaw
on one and one to moore
curveball lined right into the glove of
max muncie at first and the inning is
over kylo for one has
flying out to bellinger in center field
why not nobody on three and one to kyle
swinging a drive deep to right field
back she goes going going and goodbye
baseball right underneath the headed
here cafe
way back into the lower deck kyle seeger
with his fifth home run of the season
his second off a left-hander this year
it comes off a kershaw tonight and the
mariners are on the board it's now the
dodgers four
and the mariners won on a long home run
to right field by kyle seeger how about
that base is loaded and two out and it's
up to chris taylor
that's a third turner at second
bellinger at first
taylor takes lowen inside it goes all
the way to the backstop and the score is
betts
and the dodgers take now a 5-1 lead
three balls no strikes
pitch to taylor
low and inside ball four so the dodgers
have been gifted with four walks
here in the fifth
the bases are loaded once again
this time max muncie coming up
gilboa looks in has a sign for modem
and the left-handers 2-2 on the way to
muncie swinging a fly ball into center
field going back bishop near the winning
track braden is there and will make the
catch and that will retire the side
dodgers get one they leave three halfway
point we go to the bottom of the fifth
and the one two on the way to law
got him to chase the sliders strike
three and clayton kershaw stands alone
in second place in the dodger all-time
list for strikeouts
two thousand four hundred and
eighty-seven brings up great ambition
nola at second two outs
no balls two strikes
per shaw
eyes the runner at second here's the
pitch breaking ball swung on and missed
strike three strikeout number 11 for
clayton kershaw well we go to the top of
the eighth inning leading things off is
cody bellinger
yeah bellinger
swinging a fly ball to right it's on its
way
cody bellinger hits one out
bellinger his sixth home run of the year
and his second in his many nights
the dodger lead is now six to one
so now the dodgers have runners at first
and third with two outs
and that'll bring up matt beatty here's
the pitch on the way swinging a line
shot into center field bishop is there
and braden makes the catch and that will
end the inning dodgers get one they
leave a couple
one on two outs
joseph odom is on at second base and
that'll bring up designated hitter kyle
lewis
the 2-2 and lewis
with a fly ball into short right center
in comes bellinger falling off bets and
that's going to do it another good
inning of work for jake mcgee
here is right fielder tim lopes
the dodgers are one out away from their
19th win of the season
two balls two strikes calaric delivers
swung on and missed strike three and the
dodgers through 27 games are now 11 over
500.